my agent usually sends me a script I
read it and if I'm interested then they
arrange a meeting with the director then
if I like the director and if the
director likes me we take it further we
discuss it we discuss the script any
notes I might have any suggestions for
rewrites or deletions and then if I'm
offered the job I usually go to the
read-through that's where all the actors
get together and all the heads of
department and we read the script and
again if there are any comments I give
them to the director and I usually start
the editing on the first day of
principal photography we set up the
editing rooms and then I get rushes the
following day a typical day in the
cutting room for me would be to watch
Russia's first thing in the morning at
around 9:30
my assistant usually starts at 6:30 so
that her name is Charlotte she can have
rushes for me right away i watch rushes
then I start assembling each scene and I
normally have to send the assembled
scenes to the director the same day so
my assemblies are very tightly cut
they've got soundtrack they've got sound
design if there are any green screens
I usually compose them first so that my
assistant can finesse them I layer all
the the compositions I want all the bits
and pieces if it's a visual effect I add
all the elements so I could have up to
ten elements sometimes and because it's
so time-consuming
my assistant Charlotte does them and
then we send it off at the end of the
day for the director once I've watched
the rushes I usually either call or text
the director to make them know that
everything's okay or if I have issues if
I want pickup shots or if they're
missing some of the subtext we discuss
it I like a very close relationship with
a director because I consider editing
the director's department they have to
trust me
we have to be in sync it doesn't mean we
have to agree on everything but we have
to have a fundamental understanding of
what we're trying to achieve and it's my
responsibility to make their vision come
across in the Edit well I like to work
with directors who can take a script and
elevate it and in the case of Stephen
Daldry
he creates magic he goes beyond the
script he he will insert moments and
details that no other directors will
think of so for me that's really
thrilling to get rushes and be
overwhelmed emotionally by them or laugh
out loud because they're so funny and
just directors who have good taste and
strong instincts are great for me I
originally wanted to be a fashion
photographer
I loved cameras I loved images and
interesting compositions I went to film
school and I studied still photography
and motion pictures and although I
operated a lot of a lot of films I kind
of fell into editing there was one
exercise in particular that really
resonated with me the whole class shot
one scene together and then we were
given the same rushes and most of my
friends cut in a wide shot too medium
shot to close-up and I chose to show an
image and prelab dialogue and start in
close-ups and then reveal the whole wide
shot so it was it was unconventional and
although I got top marks and praise for
my peers for me it was a turning point
so then when I finished school I ended
up as a clapper loader on a few
productions and on the the movie I was a
clapper loader on I just followed the
film through into the cutting room and
I've been there ever since
although the crown is considered
television for for Netflix
it's every episode is treated like a
feature film so for me I have the
collaboration with the director Steven
Daldry who is amazing and since he comes
from film he insists on keeping me on to
the end of the mix so as an editor I'm
able to follow the film through to the
very end
well I edited episodes 8 & 9 8 deals
with the with the Kennedys coming to
Buckingham Palace and episode 9 is about
the Gordon Stone episode with Prince
Philip and the Prince Charles and their
experiences there now both episodes were
completely different in tone so I had
the pleasure of editing a comedy and
then a very serious heartbreaking drama
so for me I had the best of both worlds
in episode 9 although it was brilliantly
written I did restructure a lot of it
because there were times when we cut
away from one boy too early and
emotionally we wanted to stay with that
one boy whether it was Charles or Philip
I also had to find interesting
transitions and so visually it was it
was a challenge to to discover where we
should switch over what shots would
complement each other
for example after Prince Philip bullies
the Queen and insists that Charles stay
at Gordon stone we added one shot of
Philip going into the hallway and
looking out the window and then there's
just a flicker of remorse and he looks
down and script wise I was meant to cut
to young Phillip on the obstacle course
but I chose to move up a shot of Charles
young Charles looking in the trophy
cabinet at young Philip and so this
juxtaposition of older Phillip cutting
to young Charles looking at his father
as a young boy in the trophy cabinet
with the trophy was emotionally very
connecting of all three characters in
the show
so I try to apply that throughout the
whole show well we all dream of getting
great performances and I was really
blessed on the crown because from the
the big leads to the tiny parts gave
brilliant performances and I have to
credit Stephen Daldry for that because
in watching every take of his rushes an
actor might do something a few times and
then Stephen will go and whisper in
their ear and then the next take is
magically ten times better because
they'll do something it could it might
be subtle but they do something that
transforms that scene so I edited the
first season of the crown as well and I
was very excited to learn that handsomer
was scoring the film so I got all his
soundtracks from all the films he had
scored and we just and I think the other
editors too tried to use his sound and
music on as a temp track on the second
season of the crown we were even luckier
because we had the first season to draw
from musically the score had the right
tone for the show had some lovely
melodies so I was able to apply those
two to my shows as temp tracks but
Stephen Daldry and I were lucky because
we went to Rupert gregson-williams home
outside of London he has a beautiful
home with rose gardens and it was very
peaceful and we spent a day with him
working on episode 9 and he just played
some melodies that we knew would work
for the show so it was a close
relationship because Rupert would also
come to our cutting room and he would
bring some tracks and we would try them
and it was a very collaborative
relationship well I think there's a
misconception that the crown has tons of
money and we get tons of time and
everything but the reality is I was
editing two shows at the same time and
so I was working 14 16 hours a day
and usually six days a week I had the
luxury of having amazing material
starting from a great script and
material that Stephen Daldry had shot so
that was a blessing but when you work on
smaller budgets with less experienced
directors I would say it sometimes is
harder because you have little material
to play with and if a director is less
experienced they sometimes give you less
freedom to explore which is detrimental
to the film because it's very healthy to
have an unbiased editors opinion and
input into the film so I would say hire
the best people for the job and let them
do their their best and explore besides
being a storyteller an editor has to be
very sensitive to the director because
although they're very talented they too
can be vulnerable so if I have anything
to say I say it one-on-one and not in
front of the writer director I try to
help them out as much as possible so
after I've watched rushes I'll either
text email or call the director and
suggest pickup shots or pickup scenes if
I think we're missing a human and
emotional beat I think of the whole
character arc which is why I watch every
take because there could be a little gem
in an unselected take I put a soundtrack
I put temp music on the on the
assemblies so and I also have the
assistant create the visual effects
after I've put my comps in there so that
I try to deliver the most finished and
polished assembly possible so that the
director can really judge how it's
shaping up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]